on cultiver cette plante aromatique
depuis l'antiquité
originaire du bassin méditerranéen le
teint est utilisée comme condiment dans
les cuisines du monde entier et
particulièrement à la réunion mais ses
vertus ne sont pas que culinaire le
thymus vulgaris est également une plante
médicinale qui traite de nombreuses
pathologies respiratoires
l'auteur y sommes moins bons c'est un
accusé qui s'y connaît pas le teint qui
a pointé un ak oui un peu faldo cas rien
bref demoun i koné peut être utilisé en
cuisine mais très peu de mots nous
pousse à pitre ont pas moins utilisable
comme petite tisane
le teint sai sont dans le bassin
méditerranéen parle t labbadia la mer
bas et les apprécier pour plaindre plein
de vertus le temps entre hot pour qu'un
domaine communal à tous li push
facilement dans les eaux comme dans les
bals il n'est pas difficile ce monde
n'aime pas trop les coins sombres et
coin ou ceux qui ne voient pas la
lumière les aime bien personnel
banksy tiges le teint une fois coupée
c'est connu on cuisine on utilise sa
province d'hakkari mais c'est ça là
c'est pour deux bonnes petites tasses en
infusion on va pas faire bouillir le
teint c'est pareil ces plantes plantes à
parfum donc on va faire bouillir l'eau
et on va verser cette eau sur le teint
qui dans la casserole
en infusion 20 minutes voilà en plus si
le teint a fleuri comme ça c'est les
bonnes occasions bon moment pour faire
des petites fissures de teint et le
teint antiseptique le teint et anti pour
les microbes les virus mais pense que le
temps pour les bronchites et un pur pour
là tout le temps pour le problème
respiratoire le teint une bonne tisane à
connaître pas seulement dans le cari le
tas il faut faire attention quand même
les madame et madame enceinte ou bien
les madame assez
fragile donc bien se renseigner comment
utiliser le temps et ne pas utiliser en
cas de
et attendent avec envoi de famille
google petit à fusion de la panne a aidé
à nice nous a bien mangé là et nous va
boire ça juste après pour bien digérer
voilà le petit isard n'est pas née alice
à nice bien mélanger la peut rajouter un
petit peu de marjolaine dedans il fera
pas de mal voilà nous les à 5,6 personne
n'avait la dose ou cinq six personnes
doit mettre ça dans un petit récipient
là pour verser là dessus de l'eau que la
goutte d'eau chaude seule bonne tasse on
va laisser ça voilà la plante
l'eau commence à changer de couleur la
voix bien et ça commence à être temps
file aussi on sent
bonne tisane surtout pas de fumier et
que t'as jamais de fumier jamais dedans
vrai avec le temps sa bonne terre un bon
terreau et le taï pousse naturellement
facile à bouturer le temps là c'est une
petite boutique on peut mettre dans un
petit pot comme ça ici trois petits
plans de teint 3 p'tites boutures de
teint en quinconce
on a une belle touffe d'ici trois quatre
mois
belle touffe de teint posé sur la voilà
bien serré bien serré bien serré voilà
un petit potin à venir
plus